I'm joined today by dr. Stephan Guillen
a an obesity researcher and health
writer whose work spans multiple fields
of science to explain and help tackle
the global weight problem he's the
author of the popular health website
Whole Health source at Whole Health
sorts org frequently lectures on the
topics of obesity metabolism and diet
history it's so great to have you on
that there's really so much here to
address and I think may be a good place
to start is talk to us a little bit
about first of all I guess the history
of weight as a problem in human society
my my guess would be that when humans
were in the pre agriculture phase in the
hunter-gatherer era that issues of
obesity were not nearly as problematic
as they were now is that a correct
assessment yeah that's absolutely right
in fact we you know it's hard to know
exactly what was going on with our pre
agricultural ancestors thousands of
years ago because most of what we have
are just bones however what we can do is
we can look at current day
hunter-gatherers and we what we know
from current day hunter-gatherers is
that obesity is very very rare in fact
I'm not aware of a single case of actual
obesity among an actual hunter-gatherer
population um there are some cases you
can find of people who would be
classified as a bit overweight but
that's about as far as it goes so I
think obesity really is a very new
problem in human history um that's not
to say it never existed actually you can
find obesity going back a long time in
agricultural societies that were
affluent such as in ancient Egypt we
know that certain Egyptian mummies had
obesity or the people who are now
mummies had obesity in life and so this
is something that goes back a long time
in affluent context but I think in terms
of the I think even in that context it
was relatively restricted to Apple and
people and whoa there was a certain
point where I mean I think the timing of
it would be
sort of as humans were starting to get
out of a sort of persistent state of
scarcity we're sort of carrying extra
weight was almost seen as a symbol of
status and and wealth and I think that
that connects to what you're saying
about affluence as well I mean in the
Roman Empire the idea of having an
abundance of food and gaining weight was
almost seen as a status symbol was it
not yeah that's right and that was true
in a lot of cultures you see that even
up until relatively recently in
Polynesian cultures for example the in
some instances the chief of the village
or the island was deliberately overfed
and often became quite obese in order to
demonstrate the affluence and power of
that group of people as a symbol
basically so yeah I think that's
absolutely right it was considered to be
a marker of affluence and something to
be desired and I think we actually see
that still a lot even in older elements
of our own culture I mean I think at
least some people will will have
memories of a grandparent telling them
to eat more and putting more food on
their plate I think that even just a
century ago in the United States that
was more the culture than it is today
yeah well I grew up in a Jewish
household so I I could tell you it's
much more recent than just a hundred
years ago that that's hahahahaha so the
concept of a diet right how far back do
we have a sense of how far back that
concept exists in human culture
yeah I'm not I'm not really an expert on
the history of dieting however I mean I
definitely have come across traces of it
going as far back as the ancient Greeks
I mean I think Hippocrates used to talk
about balancing food intake and exercise
and essentially that the two had to be
in balance for a person to remain lean
and in good health and if they were out
of balance you're eating too much food
and getting not enough exercise that you
would accumulate fat and that
had severe health consequences so I
think that kind of concept has existed
for a long time but I think people I
think as a society probably we haven't
been as obsessed about it as we are
currently ever in human history because
obesity just hasn't been as much of a
problem so how can we measure that I'd
like to jump into that next how could we
maybe quantify the extent to which
obesity and weight are a problem today
in society what are some ways that
someone like you
approaches measuring the issue yeah so
there are a variety of different data
sets that we can look at the best data
that we have goes back to about 1960 and
it uses a measure called the body mass
index and this is basically just a
measure of weight that's been corrected
for height and weight and and it's a
great measure in the sense because it's
very easy to get all you need is a
person's height and a person's weight
and so we have data pretty systematic
data from the United States going back
to about 1960 showing that our body mass
index and our body fatness therefore has
increased quite a bit over that half
century period and there's a
particularly sharp increase that started
somewhere around somewhere between the
late 70s and the early 80s but we can
actually see traces of it starting even
much earlier than that so there are data
from Civil War veterans from the late
1800s showing that only 1 in 17
middle-aged white men was obese at that
time whereas today the number is 40
something percent I think so there have
been very dramatic changes that began a
very long time ago more than a century
ago in this country now stepping up to
play devil's advocate as far as BMI I've
done quite a bit of reading on that
issue
and from what I've read it may not be
the best way to assess obesity only
because it doesn't take into account
sort of body composition that someone
who is heavy because of overeating would
be showing up similarly to someone who
has more muscle mass for example how do
you feel about some of the weaknesses of
BMI bait on that basis yeah I mean there
are definitely limitations to it as a
measure so one example I like to use is
that Arnold Schwarzenegger at his peak
at his bodybuilding peak had a BMI of I
believe it was thirty point one which
puts him just over the cusp of the obese
range and you know he had a body fat
percentage of probably something in the
five to six percent range so yeah it has
its limitations but the reality is that
most of us are not Arnold Schwarzenegger
and if you look at so the most accurate
way of measuring body fatness is to
measure it directly using things like
underwater weighing or dual x-ray
densitometry t absolute imagery and
those are things that directly measure
the amount of fat in your body so they
give you an actual body fat percentage
or kilos of body fat and if you do those
and you compare them if you do the gold
standard measures and you compare them
to BMI what you find is that about
something something like one in five
people is is miscategorized by BMI
either because they have a lot of muscle
mass or because they have not very much
muscle mass so it definitely happens but
it's not something that happens in most
people and it's also when you're looking
at population averages such as those I
was talking about in the United States
it's actually a very good measure
because some people are going to be
miscategorized in either direction but
on average it's actually a really good
measure and so I don't think anyone is
arguing for example that you know the
increase in BMI since 1970 in the United
States is because we all put on a bunch
of muscle mass so yeah it has its
weaknesses but particularly as a measure
of groups of individuals and
particularly as a measure of groups of
individuals of European or African
descent
tends to be a pretty good measure okay
so causes of obesity and weight issues
in modern society things that are thrown
around sedentary lifestyle right amount
of not doing anything versus doing
something when it comes to diet whether
it's a diet in the form of total calorie
consumption versus diet in the form of
the specific foods that are being
consumed environmental factors other
societal factors etc how can we start
putting together a picture of what the
causes are of the situation we're in
today yeah the way I like to do it to
try to get a toehold on what's going on
is to start to think about calorie
intake and calorie expenditure which is
what you're alluding to here so what you
know basically our body fatness is
determined by the number of calories
coming in versus the number leaving and
so by trying to figure out which side of
that equation calories coming in or
calories leaving is the one that we
should be focusing on that helps us kind
of deconstruct the situation and what we
see if we look at calorie expenditure in
the United States it's gone down quite a
bit over the last century I mean we used
to have very very physical jobs a lot of
the things that we did in our daily
lives like washing laundry and um making
food and taking care of the house and
things like that ah you know not having
automobiles used to be a lot more
physical so our physical activity has
definitely declined quite a bit however
that doesn't really account for the
obesity epidemic itself which is this
rapid rise in obesity prevalence that
occurred that began around the late 70s
or early 80s and what we see if we look
at that period of history is that our
physical activity didn't really change
that much it may have changed somewhat
but not that much what really changed is
our calorie intake increased by quite a
bit and what what happened was there was
this decoupling that occurred between
our food in
take our calorie intake and our calorie
needs so the human brain of body has to
some limited extent the ability to
balance those two things in control body
weight but around that time there is
this decoupling that happened where our
calorie intake just kind of went through
the roof and our physical activity did
not increase proportionally let's pick
it up though with dr. Stefan Guillen a
obesity researcher health writer his
website whole health source org we will
pick it up right there with him tomorrow
we're continuing today with dr. Stefan
DNA an obesity researcher and health
writer whose work spans multiple fields
of science to help explain and tackle
the global weight problem you can check
out his website whole health source org
we stopped yesterday talking about sort
of the general causes of the obesity and
weight problem in the United States and
we also observe it in other societies do
you have a sense of I've read this what
purports to be a rule of thumb that when
you're talking about weight loss that is
overwhelmingly some say 75 80 85 90
percent calories in and only 10 15 20 %
exercise or calorie expenditure do you
have a thought on that ratio yeah I
think it's pretty hard to put a number
on it
I think physical activity is important
however the the key thing to remember is
that you can always out eat your
physical activity so no matter how much
almost regardless of how much you're
exercising you can always out eat it so
the question is how much are you eating
relative to how much you're expending
and I think that's really the critical
thing and for me that puts that does put
the focus more on food intake in terms
of determining body fatness
I'd like to dig in a little bit to diet
more specifically and then maybe we can
talk about specific issues like fat
carbs sugar salt etc when you sort of
look at the average Western diet what's
your assessment of it I mean that the
food
pyramid that's in your mind is the ideal
pyramid and maybe it's not a pyramid
shape at all which I think what might
might be kind of interesting what does
that look like yeah so first of all the
average Western diet or at least the
average American diet is truly atrocious
so in 2010 and and honestly it really
even shocks me to see this data as much
as I've read about what we're eating in
2010 the USDA Dietary Advisory Committee
released a report showing what the top
sources of calories are in the u.s. diet
and number-one source of calories in the
u.s. diet I kid you not is a category
called grain-based desserts and this is
cake cookies donuts pastries that sort
of thing that is the number one source
of calories in the US diet and in the
top six are bread chicken Pizza soda and
alcohol that's the top six right there
so I mean the u.s. diet on average is is
really really really bad and I think
there are a lot of things that are wrong
with it and if if I were to propose a
healthier diet it would be one that's
based primarily on whole unrefined foods
that have a lower calorie density that
is fewer calories per per volume so
something for example crackers have a
very high calorie density because
there's no water in them as opposed to
oatmeal which has a lower calorie
density so foods that have a lower
calorie density that are simple natural
unrefined foods things that are more
similar to what our ancestors would have
eaten and things that don't drive are
things that don't seduce us to overeat
them like one of the Pringles that stay
bet you can't eat just one I mean these
are foods that are literally designed to
get to motivate us to purchase them and
eat them and those are the types of food
that drive us to eat too much so if we
can have a diverse unrefined omnivorous
diet I think that we would be much
better off than we are currently over
time we've seen the focus of the the
food industry the diet industry etc
often trend towards a particular aspect
of nutrition there was a period some
decades ago where the focus was fat you
should cut out fat and replace it with
other stuff and a lot of times what it
was being replaced with was as you're
talking about calorie dense but
relatively unused foods the low-carb
diets of the sort of Atkins diet same
although there's a no shortage of other
ones that focus on not eating
carbohydrates the focus on sugar as a
sort of component to be avoided what's
your sense of this are there any of
these that make particular sense to you
or any that that acutely don't make
sense I mean I think they all make some
degree of sense I think that none of
them would be as popular as they are or
at least were without some grain of
truth however I think all of them are
one component of the bigger picture
which is that all of those things fat
and sugar and carbohydrate are things
that contribute to overeating in fat
gain and cutting them out helps people
slim down that's not to say that all
diets are equally effective it is true
that low carbohydrate diets tend to help
people lose weight more effectively than
at least your standard moderate low-fat
diet so however I mean those diets all
will help you lose weight but I think
what is kind of disturbing to me is to
see people focus exclusively on one
factor and then ignore everything else
and I think sugar the sugar mania that
has gripped this country over the last I
don't know few months or maybe even
years is an example of that I think that
I mean you know I don't think sugar is
good for you I don't eat any refined
sugar or very very very little I eat
plenty of fruit a lots of fruit
um I I eat very little refined sugar I
don't think it's good for you or at
least not for most people but I also
don't think that it's the cause of all
of our ills and I don't even think it's
the main cause of all of our ills I mean
if I could choose between a know a
lifestyle where my calories were in
checking out physically active but I was
eating a fair amount of sugar and a
lifestyle where I was not active and
eating too many calories and eating no
sugar I would definitely choose the
first one over the second one I mean
there's a priority list for health and
sugar is on there somewhere but it's not
number one as far as some of the
different buzzwords that are thrown
around then sugar-free is one of them
and we've spoken extensively with
experts about how that as a marketing
tool can actually be incredibly
deceptive loaded with antioxidants
potentially has anti-inflammatory
properties etc number one how much how
accurately can we assess some of those
claims and number two is that even
really what one should be paying
attention to in terms of the composition
of their diet
no I don't think so and first of all I
think the majority of those claims
frankly are just baloney um those foods
that make claims like that are generally
not going to deliver you any benefit
whatsoever and particularly when
compared to whole unrefined foods and
the fact is that a lot of those foods
that make claims like that are the very
foods that are the most refined that are
probably contributing to the problem
more than anything so what would be an
example of that ah Sunny Delight with
vitamin C in it um I mean these are our
Tang with vitamin C you know putting
vitamin C in there is a cheap trick
basically to try to get people to think
it's healthy and instead it's just sugar
water it's colored sugar water so and
there are many many foods like this so I
think that
I think that it's very easy to be
tricked by this I mean even I am
sometimes like I don't eat bread very
often but I brought a loaf of bread the
other day and I you know I saw the bread
it looked dark it looked it said
multigrain on it and it wasn't until I
brought home that I realized it wasn't
actually whole-grain
it was multigrain which means it has
different types of refined grains in it
but it wasn't a whole green food so I
had even myself who I'm tend to be
extremely aware of this sort of thing
even even I'm able to be tricked
sometimes so I think you really have to
stick with simple heuristics like
choosing the most unrefined foods that
you can possibly choose and not cheat
and you know not even not even look at
those processed foods and decide between
them on the basis of whatever you know
health or nutrient claims they have on
the package is bread a good example of
where you can make more informed
decisions in the sense that at my local
grocery store for example you have one
area of breads which are kind of like
the more local bakeries and when you
look at the ingredient list it's like
four to six ingredients and I sort of
recognize everything that's on that list
I can also go down to the packaged bread
aisle those breads have anywhere from 15
to 25 ingredients many of which I don't
recognize are there significant
differences in terms of the the health
impact of choosing a four ingredients
ort of imagine what those ingredients
are versus one of the factory breads I
don't know maybe I I tend to think
probably how refined if the flour is is
a larger is a larger factor so and you
know I hate to be that I hate to be the
pessimist but you know that local bread
that's made with white flour is probably
not so good for you I mean white flour
is inherently not a food that is
supportive of health so yeah I mean I
personally just based on the
precautionary principle I would probably
tend to favor something that's simpler
like the local bread and certainly it
would taste better but does do those
extra ingredients make any
difference for health yeah I'm not sure
not I'm really not sure last thing I
want to touch on we have a lot of
vegetarians pescetarians we've got a
vegan working on the show you know
there's a lot of these different of
Preferences choices that people are
making with regards to animal product
consumption not from a moral or ethical
standpoint or one of animal cruelty etc
we're from a health impact where do you
fall on what share of one's diet it
makes sense to have animal products be
and feel free to distinguish between
sort of dairy and and meat if if that's
relevant sure sure yeah I mean I think
there are definitely compelling reasons
to be vegetarian and vegan and I had a
lot of respect for for people who choose
that lifestyle however humans have been
eating animal foods for you know
probably at least a hundred million
years maybe more than that our ancestors
is what I mean we evolved from
insectivores originally mammalian
insectivores and then after that we
became primates about 60 million years
ago and our animal food intake probably
went down quite a bit but almost all
primates that you insects so we probably
were never completely vegetarian or
vegan with maybe with some exceptions
like gorillas but chimpanzees our
closest living relatives they eat a
little bit of meat they eat insects
regularly and if you look at human
evolution it's really you know since the
evolution of our genus homo 2.6 million
years ago it's really a progression
toward higher calorie density of the
foods and part of that was eating more
animal foods so our ancestors have been
eating I don't want to say high levels
necessarily but variable levels some of
which were high for millions of years
and the human body really is I mean
humans truly are obligate omnivores we
cannot survive literally without some
amount of animal foods because we have
an absolute
dietary requirement for vitamin b12
which is only found in animal foods so
there's no doubt that our physiology
requires animal foods today we can
supplement with b12 and I think we can
do you know I think we can do fine at
least some people but I think that it's
more than just about the b12 I think
that human physiology has been receiving
animal foods for so long that we are
adapted to those things and I think I
think there's much less of a difference
between being an omnivore and being a
vegetarian and in terms of nutrition and
physiology than there is between being a
vegetarian and a vegan because there
when you're when you're eating a vegan
diet there you're not eating any animal
foods and so there's a whole like swath
of nutrients that you're going to have
that you're either not getting or you're
going to have a harder time getting some
of those are essential nutrients like
b12 some of them are non essential
nutrients like creatine something that
enhances physical performance and and
there are probably other things that we
don't even know about yet that the human
body is just accustomed to because it's
been receiving those things for millions
and millions of years so and then that
brings us to the question of how much we
should be eating and I don't really have
a definitive answer for that but I would
say that the healthy if we go looking
for the healthiest cultures we can find
um that are not hunter-gatherers people
who are living a little bit more like
we're living in the modern world today
you tend to find the healthy healthiest
people do not generally eat a lot of
meat so they're omnivores I mean every
culture in the world is omnivore is
omnivorous unless they have some kind of
religious restriction on meat every
culture in the world eats meat um and
and some sort of animal food but I think
that the quantities that you see in the
cultures that have longer lifespans and
better chronic disease rate
it's tend to be lower and so you know
myself personally not as much for health
reasons more for environmental reasons I
tend to eat less meat than most people
but I do eat some meat absolutely
fascinating very very informative we've
been speaking with dr. Stefan DNA who's
an obesity researcher and health writer
I encourage you to check out his website
whole health source org so great to talk
to you thank you so much thanks David